presidential run today you plan on
following soon wouldn't you like to know
internet I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report on February 15th 2023
we're live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and locals share subscribe tap that
notification Bell if you have not and if
you want to join us for the post game
show where you can add comments you can
correct me if I make any factual errors
and a whole bunch more you can join us
at
reubenreport.locals.com a little bit of
a shift today I want to talk about some
of the weird Juju that's out there not
j-e-w-j-e-w Juju there's just some weird
energy out there a lot of bizarre things
happening chemical spills and balloons
from China and Senators having strokes
and weird things happening are they
coincidental pipelines blowing up or is
there some sort of script that we're all
just reacting to constantly I don't know
the answer to that but we're gonna go
through some of it because it does seem
like the regular our day-to-day
political stuff has slowed down just a
little bit right we rolled into the new
year Republicans took over Congress we
had a couple hearings this last week or
so feels like it's cooled off in terms
of just like nitty-gritty political
Republicans are doing this Democrats are
doing that we got through the state of
the union now it's just like a whole
bunch of weird stuff I mentioned
yesterday this massive massive explosion
and chemical spill in East Palestine
Ohio that the media has completely
ignored not only the media but our
government has completely ignored and
then finally
it happened I believe 12 days ago we're
going to show you a whole bunch of
pictures and videos finally after the
last two or three days of people online
sharing videos and it's one of the
reasons that they don't want you to be
able to share videos online so that they
can control the narrative uh eventually
because enough people shared videos kids
were out there literally kids 15 year
olds that live in the area were out
there on the streets showing videos of
dead fish and dead birds and chemical
burns and all of this stuff then the
mainstream media finally comes around to
it and gay Pete our transportation
secretary who only got the job because
he's a homosexual he had no
qualifications other than doing homo
things uh he finally 12 Days Later
commented on it with two tweets we'll
get to that and the real question and I
suppose for the show today is who is
responsible for all the weird stuff
that's happening right now and who is
going to to do something about it and
what is their motive and are any of
those things connected that's what we
will try to decipher today a on the
Reuben report before we get to it let me
talk to you guys about Birch gold You
know despite the U.S blowing through the
31.4 trillion dollar debt ceiling in
January the leftist White House still
refuses to reduce spending while our
national leadership has buried their
heads in the Sands when it comes to
fiscal responsibility it's time to pull
yours out that would be a great time to
diversify into gold with Birch gold in
times of high uncertainty and
instability gold is King it's Dependable
Birch gold makes it easy to convert an
IRA or 401K into an IRA and precious
metals here's what you need to do visit
birchgold.com Dave to claim your free
info kit on gold and then talk to one of
their precious metals Specialists think
about this to dig our country out of
this mountain of debt every single
taxpayer in America would have to write
a check for about 250 Grand and it's
only getting worse protect yourself with
gold today by visiting birchgold.com
Dave they've got an A-Plus rating with
the Better Business Bureau thousand the
happy customers and countless five star
reviews go to birchgold.com Dave and now
back to me okay so let's talk about all
of this uh from the top down Joe Biden
always says we want a bottom-up economy
what does he say we have a bottom-up
economy in the sideways it goes out like
this and this and this but he's always
got everything backwards but clearly
clearly one thing that has been
Unearthed over these last couple years
of covid craziness and climate craziness
and big Tech craziness is that there are
a series of groups led by some pretty I
would say terrible people who really
want to control your life they want to
decide when you can go outside and what
foods you can eat and what stove you can
cook on and what temperature you can
keep your house and much more of course
the leader the the pinup model
for this is the world economic forum's
Klaus Schwab he is she Palpatine in
reality well we know we had the world
economic Forum uh Summit just a couple
weeks ago now they have another one it's
happening right now it's called the
world government Summit these people
it's all like right out of isn't the
world governments of it isn't that what
the uh the Super Friends were fighting
oh that was the Legion of Doom all right
close enough guys you got it that's
where all the bad guys hung out you
remember anyway here is Klaus Schwab at
the world government Summit and somehow
he seems to know that we're going to
have a Black Swan event
um a Black Swan event by the way is
something really really bad happens all
over the world take a look
and the last factor I want to mention
is resilience
the capability
to bounce back
because there will be
certainly
what he calls a black swans see
unpleasant surprises which will come
in our way
certainly be endless surprises well if
they're endless surprises then I don't
think they're certainly there the Black
Swan events they're gonna come sort of
like covid that kind of fit the
narrative that a one-world government
guy would like get the forces of Western
freedom and the Defenders of liberal
democracies liberal in the right sense
of the word liberal and the the
governments that defend individual
freedoms notably the United States
America at the top of that list get them
to crush their own laws get them to
eliminate dissent and silence their own
citizens that's what this guy wants to
do at something called the world
government Forum there's no such thing
as the world government they would like
to create one but no you as a citizen if
you're watching this from the United
States you only have to abide by the
laws of the United States of America
your state and your country and when
those laws are unjust then you have to
figure out how to change those laws
within within the laws because we have
pretty good system of laws to go out go
out there and amend things and change
things and all that but they're not
happy about that because they want one
government so whether you live in the
United States or you lived in Sweden or
you live in Chad or you live in
Switzerland or give me another fun
country my friend
Austria I don't know where I thought you
were going to go somewhere in Asia but
the point is they want to control you
who's another person that wants to
control you and how does she want to do
it it's Greta funberg Greta thundberg
who no doubt flies all over the place in
private jets you remember the video a
couple weeks ago we played of her being
arrested by German authorities but the
whole thing was stage first she took a
bunch of pictures with them all smiling
they made sure the handcuffs are on nice
and loose so that they carry her away
and everyone's giggling she's got a new
book out people here's a tweet from
Greta funberg I'm so pleased to share it
that the climate book is now available
in the U.S and Canada I have gathered
wisdom of over 100 contributors to
highlight the many different crises we
face and equip us with the knowledge we
need to avoid the climate disaster this
is was there a little more there
that was it it was just one tweet I
think she had two tweets originally
that's all right uh anyway she's putting
out a book to freak people out just like
John Kerry who became super rich on the
climate grift Al Gore who's worth a
couple hundred million dollars after
being VP
on the climate grift this is what they
do and they want to control you climate
change is the next one and would it
surprise you if the very people who
purport to be all about the environment
and green technologies and they love the
Earth but you evil Republicans hate it
because somehow you care about
capitalism or something like that would
it surprise you if they were actually
the ones doing the most damage to the
environment uh and not only doing the
most damage to the environment but doing
the most damage to the people
who live on this Earth speaking of that
the EU Parliament has just voted to ban
petrol car sales by 2035 how they're
going to replace them no idea but here's
uh some applauding after the vote vote
is closed
and it is adopted and thereby the first
reading of parliament is closed thank
you
[Applause]
very exciting guys no more petrol cars
in the EU by 2035 we don't know how
we're gonna you know keep people on the
roads or if any of this makes sense but
we just do things that sort of sound
right we'll deal with the consequences
later speaking of consequences there is
let's get to this East Palestine story
This is Wild so East Palestine is a
little town in Ohio you have probably
never heard of it before this uh it is a
little town as we're going to show some
clips of Tucker Carlson explaining
what's going on there in a moment but as
he notes a lot of white people so this
isn't doesn't really fit the narrative
you know if you know because white
people can't be uh victims according to
the government uh well on February 3rd
12 days ago there was an unbelievable I
don't even know what the right adjective
to use to describe it is just an
absolutely astoundingly horrific
disaster a train accident that then
released on unbelievable amount of
chemicals into the air fire explosions
the whole thing here's a little video
about it that was making the rounds
online
Train derailed Friday 20 of them
carrying hazardous materials as flames
lit up the sky in northeastern Ohio the
evacuation order is in place for anyone
within a mile radius of the crash site
these aren't these aren't storm clouds
this is the
[Music]
this is not storm clouds
look at it
[Music]
officials are claiming that the air and
water are safe
residents say they can still smell
chlorine they've complained about their
eyes watering when they go outside and
one woman says the noxious Heir killed
her chickens I don't know where he just
started coughing really hard and just
shut down and went very fast
[Music]
look at all these crows I'm not
kidding this is within 10 miles of East
Palestine
[Music]
please leave the area
okay so the images and the video we
could go on and on with all that I want
to get into a little bit of the
specifics now first off I just want to
talk about the timeline on this thing
this happened 12 days ago I don't think
I even heard about it until about three
or four days ago and I could be what's
called a very online person so this was
not making the rounds eventually it
started gaining traction online thus I'm
talking about it today but we did a
quick scan of virtually every CNN anchor
that we could find on Twitter and MSNBC
anchor in New York Times nurse nobody is
talking about this and certainly nobody
was talking about it for 10 days putting
aside everything else if you see a
massive explosion of that nature is that
not newsworthy relative to I don't know
what's going on in America like just on
the NBC Nightly News and today there was
a train derailment and a crazy massive
explosion we don't know about all the
chemicals yet but this is Worth showing
just visually all the flames it's it's
something but they all went absolutely
bark on this and as I often say one of
the things that you now know about the
news is when they're not talking about
something that probably is the thing to
be talking about right like that really
is it Anyway Tucker Carlson of course
Tucker is one of the few people that is
doing anything roughly approximate to
honesty in in corporate media uh here he
is summarizing the conditions of East
Palestine
East Palestine is overwhelmingly white
and it's politically conservative more
than 70 percent of the voters in the
surrounding County supported Donald
Trump in the last election that
shouldn't be relevant but as you're
about to hear it very much is
11 days ago 150 car Train derailed in
East Palestine and when it did it spewed
poisonous chemicals onto the ground and
into the surface waters after the crash
the Ohio State EPA found evidence of
butyl acrylate in the Ohio River as well
as in the creeks and streams that feed
it now this was a concern for more than
simply East Palestine given that the
Ohio River supplies drinking water to
about a tenth of the entire U.S
population
so this train derailment was an
environmental disaster not an
environmental disaster like climate
changes but an actual environmental
disaster okay so this is serious stuff
10 of drinking water to Americans right
you can look at all the videos of the
Dead Fish and the dead frogs and the
dead birds and other animals and the
chickens dying on top of the fact that
we already have this national issue with
chickens not laying eggs we haven't
covered that yet but that's another one
right now that's really bizarre and then
the EPA shows up now you would think we
have this whole movement
in America and and seemingly a global
movement that endlessly cares about the
environment right you should not turn
lights on you should not drive this car
you shouldn't cook your eggs on that
stove and they're always screaming about
it but for some reason with this thing
these toxic chemicals in our water this
unbelievable I mean these fires in the
plume of smoke we're going to show you
another image on that that looks like an
atom bomb was dropped there there
they're being awfully quiet on this uh
here's a little bit more from Tucker but
we basically nuke the town with
chemicals
so then representatives from the EPA the
Environmental Protection Agency arrived
to restore com yes an EPA spokesman
explained chemicals from the derail
train did enter the local Watershed and
yes they did Kill fish but the drinking
water supply remains totally safe the
fish are dead but go ahead and fill your
thermos and Brew some coffee
everything's fine
now we don't know if the locals in East
Palestine are drinking the water tonight
but we can tell you the buy
demonstration doesn't seem too concerned
about it either way Donald Trump got
over 71 percent of the vote in the
county in the last presidential election
that's not exactly the Democratic
party's core demographic
fentanyl toxic waste spill whatever
they're not our voters okay in one
instance here I don't want to be quite
as cynical as Tucker as being on the
election side of this thing so I don't
know that the administration is ignoring
this because these are you know like
white Trump voters there I don't know
that much I wouldn't put it past this
administration because I think they're
pretty bad people but I don't know that
much the point really is that there is a
reason they are ignoring this ecological
disaster I don't know that we know that
reason yet but for the EPA to show up
there the Environmental Protection
Agency which is an extremely well-funded
agency that has gone well beyond the
bounds of what it was originally founded
to do that it is telling people drink
the water drink the water with all the
freaking dead fish and the dead frogs go
ahead and drink that water I have to say
guys I have always been leery of the uh
the EPA the Environmental Protection
Agency because I'm a child of the 80s
and I remember this very important
moment I think this was around 1986 and
this locked in my mind what a bunch of
frauds the EPA are
foreign
excuse me this is private property shut
this off shut these all off I'm warning
you turning off these machines would be
extremely hazardous I'll tell you what's
hazardous you're facing Federal
prosecution for at least a half a dozen
environmental violations now either you
shut off these beams or we shut them off
for you
as you guys know that was Walter Peck
from the Environmental Protection Agency
and what did he do Phoenix that's right
he shut off the Ecto Plasma containment
unit the Ecto containment unit something
there was some plasma there too and what
happened all the ghosts escaped all hell
broke loose throughout the city a couple
years later they're you know fighting
this pink slime thing you got it guys
then they release a movie with all
chicks which was horrible the social
justice Warriors go nuts you see what
I'm saying here all right let's get back
to the series stuff uh here's a tweet
from Benny Johnson with with an image of
the plume of smoke over East Palestine I
mean this is just absolutely wild and I
thought what I thought Manny's uh
commentary on this was quite good he
says important reminder that the CDC the
NIH Dr fauci and every vaccine mandate
Tyrant who screamed at you to wear a
mask so we can stay safe are totally
silent as children breathe in this black
death the Karens never cared about your
safety they only cared about power evil
for us I mean look at that image that
image if you just saw that with no
context you would think that a massive
bomb maybe an atom bomb was dropped on a
city somewhere far across the world that
is in America in the heartland of
America in Ohio within the last week or
so that is absolutely just wild so I
want to talk a little bit more
about the abject failure not only of our
media but of our politicians because
obviously Biden's barely talking about
it gay Pete our transportation secretary
somehow has been busy doing some other
stuff mostly making sure white people
don't get jobs at the federal government
we'll talk about that in just a second
but then one more odd ecological thing
that happened I believe this is
yesterday here is video of a truck
filled with nitric acid that tipped over
in Tucson Arizona what is going on here
let's see
is it a Road fire no oh my god oh yeah
[Music]
okay so I am not sitting here telling
you that these things are connected I am
not sitting here telling you that these
things are intentional but what I am
telling you is that something weird is
going on here the way the media does not
react to these things however if Donald
Trump was president and this had
happened of course they would be blaming
him they would be saying ah you see why
this Train derailed in East Palestine it
was because Donald Trump doesn't fund
the EPA and we've defunded the roads and
bridges
but they do everything for narrative so
now gay Pete as you know I call him gay
Pete because he only got the job because
he's gay he was the mayor of South Bend
Indiana it is a tiny little city what
what about 120 000 people or something
we've checked this before something like
120 000 people South Bend Indiana uh he
is a sort of mini Obama clone he comes
off as deeply inauthentic he is
completely unqualified for the job so
for 10 days about it might even been 11
11 and a half days he did not address
this this is the transportation
secretary I don't know what his job is
other than to address massive disastrous
trained derailments that seems like it
would be kind of at the top of the list
but here he is a day or two ago not
addressing what's going on in East
Palestine but he is concerned that too
many white people are working in the
Department of Transportation
to work with your contractors to work
with your community colleges on building
a Workforce that reflects the community
we have heard way too many stories from
Generations past of infrastructure where
you got a neighborhood often a
neighborhood of color that finally sees
the project come to them but everyone in
the hard hats on that project looking
like uh you know doing doing the good
paying jobs don't look like they came
from anywhere near the neighborhood
right you can build community wealth
that will help close wealth gaps in this
country if we can tear down those
barriers but that happens at the
delivery level
see how whacked out I was going to say a
bad word I'll be nice do you see how how
really ridiculous these people are so
what Pete is saying there is that now
when John when projects let's say road
projects infrastructure projects come to
largely black communities that the
people there are upset because the
workers don't look like them who walks
around in that state of racial psychosis
except a modern Progressive oh my God
they're here and they're fixing the
roads can I get the color breakdown on
those people that guy over there pouring
the tar is Asian can we count the think
how profoundly stupid it is but speaking
of profoundly stupid we just check some
numbers South Bend Indiana where gay
Pete was the mayor the unqualified
Transportation secretary gay Pete 75
percent white why did gay Pete not put
some white people on trains it's coming
put some white people on trains and bust
in some black people
I don't know why gay people didn't do
that you're going to have to bring that
up with gay people but gay Pete finally
did tweet about East Palestine finally
12 Days Later here's what he said I
continue to be concerned about the
impact of the February 3rd train
derailment near East Palestine Ohio and
the effects on families in the 10 days
since their lives were upended through
no fault of their own funny he didn't
comment on it for 10 days it's important
that families have access to useful and
accurate information
usdot that's Department of
Transportation has been supporting the
investigation led by the national trade
Transportation safety board our federal
rail Administration and pipelines and
hazardous material teams were on site
within hours of the initial incident and
continue to be actively engaged
so he said nothing that's just a bunch
of nothing and he did it 10 days later
and we are to believe that this guy is
in charge of the Department of
Transportation we have a massive
environmental disaster the
environmentalists are being silent and
we have been completely unqualified
um head of the the transportation
department it is insane I did see a few
memes of Pete that I thought were worthy
of showing so I tweeted these out if you
want them I'll post them in the locals
community so you could snag those images
yourself there you go there's Pete with
his helmet riding away from the giant
ecological disaster there's Pete smiling
he's thinking about the environmental
disaster and there's Pete with his open
cardigan today I solved racism at
construction times look at the end of
the day you have to laugh about these
people that's not to diminish what's
going on there but like these people are
absolutely ridiculous how ridiculous are
they well Pete continued two days ago
where he's still at this point had not
even tweeted about the the incident in
East Palestine and here he is making
jokes about that Chinese spy balloon and
that's where our partnership comes in
we're providing again more funding but
you all are going to need to put
together the local information and the
localized inputs on the applications
about where some of these Chargers
actually need to go right so that's just
one example of the partnership that that
we are building up but it couldn't be a
more exciting time for Transportation uh
it's had its challenges right uh I mean
if you look at what the American
Transportation Systems have faced in the
last two or three years
partly because of the pandemic we've
faced issues from container shipping to
airline cancellations now we got
balloons that's right
um
but
also the best time ever to be working
Transportation because of these
resources and we know ultimately it's in
the hands of those who are on the ground
that the biggest difference is going to
be made he's just nothing what he is is
a guy with a tight haircut and a
well-fitting suit who sounds like Obama
who knows nothing of what he speaks to
joke about the Chinese spy balloon I
joke about everything but it's not like
this guy is a jokester right like so he
he dismisses it what he wants is you to
dismiss it he wants you to every time
you hear Chinese spy balloon or our
airspace has been violated or anything
else to just it's just kind of funny
that's just something Republicans think
about right it's not something real we
have no idea first off how many of these
have come over and we blew up one over
Canada we don't know what information
they were getting from secret military
sites and nuclear sites that they were
flying over and what they transmitted
back to the Chinese balloons it's kind
of funny it's kind of funny by the way
as we were playing that clip my man
Chris working remote
from another location not in Florida
he's our employee not in Florida he has
his reasons uh he did a little Googling
52 of construction workers are not white
so that right 52 not white or 52 are
white oh 52 are white but that's pretty
close to 50 50. so if you really care
whether the guy who is painting the
lines in the middle of the road is white
or black you pretty much got a 50 chance
that he's white or black or
miscellaneous okay these people
are on serious ridiculous clowns oh
speaking of unserious ridiculous clowns
uh Joe Biden is the elderly man
pretending to be president uh he did an
interview here and you can see that the
drugs were wearing off in the middle of
it he starts losing himself uh which
often happens and uh he's also telling
us not to worry about that balloon
thingy wasn't it a major break security
bridge for the United States just the
fact that the balloon came into the
airspace and flew over the country for
so many days oh look
the total amount of
intelligence Gatherings going on by
every country around the world is
overwhelming and the idea that a balloon
could Traverse uh break American
airspace is uh
anyway
it's it's not a major breach you must
understand that Joe Biden has no idea
what he's saying and you could see the
thought sort of just jumping away from
him as he's saying it it is very clear
that a violation of our airspace is a
problem and we do not know what was
being transmitted or perhaps we've
subsequently found it out and they're
not telling us I don't trust anything
from this Administration anyway but his
dismissal of this well then why did we
blow the one up over China why did we
wait to blow this one up why didn't we
just send it back to them and then send
a sternly written uh strongly worded
letter you Chinese people stop sending
her balloons
what do you think it is Chinese New Year
no more balloons
he's just ridiculous uh but watch this
this is just great because as you know
it's not just Biden that's incompetent
it's not just uh Pete that's incompetent
it's the entire Administration that's
incompetent but why do they somehow get
people to vote for them because they
have an entire structure of mainstream
media powered by big Tech that goes out
of its way to defend them it not only
does that but it would do the complete
reverse if it was a republican in charge
so here's a nice video compilation of
the leftist media holding water carrying
water for Joe Biden Republicans argued
that the balloon the size of three
school buses should have been taken out
over the Pacific if you're Biden you're
kind of damned if you do damned if you
don't let's say he had shot this down
somewhere over the country all this
metal and glass comes clanging to Earth
and could have hurt somebody and it
lands on something hurts somebody three
buses worth of metal will be falling
down potentially on hospitals
potentially on kindergartens that could
hit a kindergarten a hospital heaven
forbid fall on a kindergarten or a
hospital isn't it defensible that they
would not want to take down something
that could have hit a school or a church
or a farmhouse it's easy to start
spinning in the absence of more concrete
information obviously this is serious
but I thought that producers had
smelling salts off of the on the side of
the set for Republicans who came on
Republicans practically tripped over
themselves over the weekend to call out
President Joe Biden oh my God this is I
mean just hyperventilating about this is
there a specific a specific part of the
country where they think or say
specifically this is where it should
have been shot down I mean what are they
talking about we should have shot down
this balloon over the aleutians well
there there's they simply don't know
Jake the administration did what
politicians usually say they want
administrations to do uh follow the
advice of of the Pentagon
guys the shrapnel might fall on a
hospital or on a kindergarten there were
a million opportunities to blow this
thing up I'm not diminishing the fact
that you don't want three buses
busworths of uh of metal to fall on
people but you also don't want a enemy
rival Nation uh taking pictures and
video of say your nuclear sites or other
top secret information now I know we're
not that very good when it comes to
protecting top secret or classified
information often I'm told if you keep
it near a Corvette that somehow will
keep you safe but of course this is just
the complete reverse imagine if Trump
was President a Chinese spy balloon went
over and then Trump didn't shoot it down
until it had traversed the whole country
and everything else the exact same
frauds that you just watched there would
be saying this proves that China is in
charge and they have information on
Trump and somehow this is related to
Russia and Trump is weak and blah blah
blah blah you get it but really the
point of all of this really is that why
is it that these people three weeks ago
or whatever it was two and a half weeks
ago felt that the Chinese spy balloon as
it was traversing the country it was the
biggest freaking deal known to man uh
but then
they will defend the guy who's so
nonchalantly dealt with it right and who
clearly doesn't even know what he's
doing China has satellites that spy on
us we have satellites that spy on China
they don't need a balloon so what type
of provocation really was this what
really is going on here that I don't
have the answer to but I assure you you
will not get the answer by watching
corporate press uh interestingly here is
video of from CBS news that U.S
intelligence knew the balloon was on its
way before it even got here so we could
have blown it up when it wouldn't have
fallen on a hospital a kindergarten a
bowling alley or God forbid an ice
skating rink back here in Washington
there is breaking news tonight on that
Chinese spy balloon CBS News has just
learned that U.S intelligence watched
the high-flying Airship as it lifted off
near China's South Coast that means the
U.S military had been tracking it for
nearly a week before it entered U.S
airspace longer than originally known
cbs's Nancy Cordes is at the White House
so Nancy they were watching this from
the beginning
they were Nora and what they saw was
this balloon heading east from China
towards Guam and Hawaii but then it took
a sharp northward turn a beeline towards
Alaska they also revealed today that the
three subsequent objects they shot down
probably were not involved in spying
the three objects shot down this weekend
may have been harmless research balloons
that's now a leading theory for the
intelligence Community there's strong
consideration that these objects are
indeed benign they won't know for sure
until they find the debris they're very
difficult terrain the chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff described the
challenge one object came down in the
Arctic Circle where it's minus 40
degrees the second came down in a hard
to reach part of the Canadian Rockies
and the third plunged into Lake Huron a
couple of hundred feet deep we'll get
them eventually but it's going to take
some time to recover those do you guys
get what happened here we knew the thing
was coming and then it's on its way to
Guam it's on its way to Hawaii and it's
on its way to Alaska and we didn't do
anything about it uh I'm not a geologist
I don't have a map in front of me or
even well I guess I've got a globe
behind me but you know what's between
Guam and Hawaii and Alaska
water
cool crisp
refreshing water and we could have blown
this thing up we could have blown it up
the safe let's just say we were just we
just we don't know they're just sending
out their little benign balloon it's
floating around we don't know what's
happening it does seem like it's going
in our Direction but okay we don't want
to you know we don't want to be you know
intentionally provocative how about the
moment across U.S airspace since when do
we let other countries just fly some
in we don't know what it is might
be benign it could be an EMP who knows
let's just see what happens it's so
profoundly ridiculous that it is
well speaking of profoundly ridiculous
I've got a clip of Justin Trudeau
because he's concerned because UFOs are
flying over North America and you know
we had to shoot one down over his
country because he was probably busy you
know buying new socks
Nora told the Associated Press this
weekend that they have an idea of what
this aircraft is is there any reason we
don't have more information on what this
aircraft is our Focus right now is on
recovering it obviously uh there is much
analysis going on at the highest levels
of NORAD in both Canada and the United
States to try and understand more to
facilitate in the location of the object
and to understand better uh you know and
be able to answer the questions that
Canadians have and as soon as we have
more clarity and better answers to give
to Canadians we will be giving them so
this is uh three aircraft shot down this
weekend I don't know if this past
weekend do we have no idea whether this
is a pattern or whether these are
connected
well I think obviously there is some
sort of pattern in there the fact that
we are seeing this uh in a significant
degree over the past week is a cause for
uh interest and and uh uh close
attention uh which is exactly what we're
doing we've employed signif deployed
significant resources here uh to be able
to recover the uh the object as well as
uh diplomatic and international
engagements going on uh to find more
information and to get Solutions on this
you got it it's just meaningless dribble
also why was he reporting from Hoth the
ice planet of hot did you see the
Taunton run by him back there which was
making me think you remember at the
beginning of Empire Strikes Back do you
know how the whole thing begins since
Trudeau was obviously standing on hot
remember the rebels have a base and
Vader he's pissed and he wants to take
out the rebels especially that Skywalker
dude who just blew up his big ship the
Death Star at the end of part one so
what does he do he sends a bunch of
satellite spies they're not balloons but
they're electronic devices he shoots
them all over the Galaxy one lands in
hot they find the the satellite there
the spy satellite and then what is Han
Solo and Chewie do when they're first
they have to save Luke from the Wampa
wait did that happen after did they save
Luke from the Wampa first or after and
it moot point that's a sidebar but what
do they do they don't wait to go is that
thing benign or is it actually spying on
us and they're going to blow up our
generator and we're not gonna be able to
get the ships off hot they blow the
something up you see the point
guys we're governed by morons I would
much rather have whoever was in charge
the rebel leader at hot would be a hell
of a lot better than Justin Trudeau
here's Karin John Pierre and she doesn't
know what's going on
the criticism of uh coming from the
lawmakers that the president hasn't
spoken out more on this uh should we
expect to hear from at some point or is
part of the reason that we're not
hearing from him because as you said
people shouldn't be panicking is there a
concern I don't have a I don't have any
um any announcement or anything to
preview on a potential
um you know remarks by the president
should people be panicking you know a
bunch of UFOs were shooting things down
spy balloons over here she don't have
anything she how the hell am I supposed
to know I I just put on these colorful
outfits and do my perm and get out there
and just say I don't know what I'm doing
that's my job
guys there were so many Bad actors here
there are Bad actors like across the
board our political leaders our media
leaders our Tech leaders there's just so
many like corrupt buffoons in charge of
everything right now it is thank God we
live in Florida so right after this show
instead of punching a random person as I
used to do when we lived in California I
could just walk outside and see a lizard
that really is what's keeping me going
at this point they lied to you guys they
lie about everything and they will lie
again and and you must just keep going
to the truth you must not fear the mob
judgment if you say well I'm curious
about that balloon over there and I'm a
little worried about that atom bomb
looking explosion over there and all of
that stuff we have to focus on what we
can control that's all of our local
stuff right that's what states rights
and all that is about because now to get
us back to the beginning of the show
when we talked about this one world
government well Klaus Schwab continued
at the conference and tell me if this
doesn't I mean the guy is right out of
casting 101 give me the most evil
sounding guy possible with the most evil
sounding script could you do that here
we go and we are just now where we move
into the exponential phase
and I agree
artificial intelligence but not only
artificial intelligence
but also submit Travelers
in your space Technologies and I could
go on and on synthetic biology
our life in 10 years from now would be
completely different very much affected
and
who Masters those Technologies
in some way will be the master of the
world
if you master those Technologies you'll
be the master of the world
sort of god-like remember when John
Kerry said we're like Gods we're like
God's here doing our environmental
things we're so great we're such gods
I mean like the script you get it like
who would say something like that but
there's just tons of them there are tons
of them and they're Hypocrites and
they're liars and they're buffoons and
they would never live the way they want
you to live so here is a guy who
invented viruses not not the first
inventor of viruses but invented viruses
on computers I'm pretty sure I can say
that I'm sure News Guard is going to
fact check me but remember when
computers came out like sort of
ubiquitously Across America late 80s
early 90s we started you know the Apple
computer was first then we had these IBM
computers then all these knockoffs and
they all had windows and then suddenly
viruses you would go to open up a window
there would be a virus five more viruses
and mostly you kids don't know this but
back in our day when we had computers
and we'd sit at the desk with the
computer mostly you were just closing
windows because viruses just kept
popping up it was just a lot people's
fingers were like this they couldn't
they had there was a condition because
you were just all day long closing
viruses on your computer of course
Windows was created by Bill Gates Bill
Gates is the biggest climate hypocrite
there is he got asked by a journalist
about his climate hypocrisy and what he
tries to back out of it but
what do you say to the charge that if
you are a climate change campaigner but
you also travel around the world in a
private jet you're a hypocrite
well I I buy the gold standard of
funding climb Works to do direct air
capture that far exceeds my family's
carbon footprint and I spend billions of
dollars on on climate Innovation so you
know should I stay at home and not come
to Kenya and learn about farming and
malaria
anyway I mean I'm I'm comfortable with
the idea that
not only am I
not part of the problem by paying for
the offsets but uh also through the
billions that my breakthrough Energy
Group
is spending that I'm part of the
solution no you're not part of the
solution and yes you should stay home
much like you endorsed for us plebs to
stay at home and be locked down when you
uh were of course staying home during
covid you have I don't know he's
probably got a dozen houses you know
billions of dollars worth of real estate
he's the number one Farmland owner in
the United States should he not get on
his private plane and go to Kenya I'm
pretty sure the people of you know the
Bill Gates plane is landing you think of
people like oh it's Bill Gates we're so
excited Bill Gates is here Bill Gates
uh we just have to keep exposing these
people because they will mandate more
rules on your life and an awful lot of
people are going to disappoint you when
they do they will come back with masks
whether it's covid9 or environment
related or whatever it might be they
will come back with more booster shots
and all of the stuff and and this one's
going to blow your mind I saw this one
yesterday this is just incredible do you
know this is true labels and jellies
moons this is totally true that the CDC
the Center for Disease Control is still
recommending masks on two-year-olds now
and they refuse to reverse it so
Rochelle wilenski who is in charge of
the CDC she was testifying yesterday in
front of Congress still defending this
concept I do want to mention one thing I
I told you guys when we went to DC a
couple months back that I was walking
they have the tunnel I think that goes
between what was it between the capital
and the uh where the where Congress the
Congressional office is basically so
there's this underground tunnel we're
walking through the tunnel and I walked
right by walensky like we basically
touched shoulders and there was
something about her I kid you not we all
looked at each other like she does not
seem human she might be some sort of
lizard person News Guard you can check
me on that one because I'm pretty sure
we'll find something very disturbing and
cold-blooded anyway here's cdc's
Rochelle wilinsky defending masks on
two-year-olds yesterday in fact the CDC
is currently the only National or
International public health agency that
recommends masking two-year-old children
I'd like you to explain in detail the
process in the timeline by which
evidence such as this is used by the CDC
to update modify or necessary withdraw
current guidance great thank you for the
opportunity to clarify on those points
so I believe you're referring to the
Cochrane review study this is an
important study but the Cochrane review
only includes randomized clinical trials
and as you can imagine many of the
randomized clinical trials that were
included in that were for other
respiratory viruses not covet 19. some
of them were for covid-19 just to be
clear but it is very different for
covid-19 because you have a pre-advirus
that a different from flu potentially
different from SARS or MERS transmits
before you actually have symptoms it's
also the case that one of the
limitations in that study was clearly
stated that people were not actually
engaged in the intervention so you
actually have to wear the mask for it to
work okay so there are lots of studies
now in Georgia why are we masking our
kids today you know thank you also so
our guidance for school-based masking is
related to our kova 19 Community levels
and fortunately we're in a place now in
this country where most of our country
is in green or yellow so what is your
timeline for updating reevaluating these
guide guidance you know our masking
guidance doesn't really change with time
what it changes with is disease your
abject nonsense now I hope and I know if
you're watching this show you are no
longer listening to the CDC and you
should not
you don't have to listen to me you
should make whatever choices are right
for you and your family and everything
else I can tell you I got two kids
downstairs uh both of whom are actually
a little under the weather right now and
David's a little under the weather too
we're running an infirmary here right
now I'm the only one operating 100 so
I'm gonna have a very crazy day after I
finish this there's gonna be a lot of
spit up all over me is what it is that's
just fine
um I am never putting masks I mean the
idea that you would put a mask on a
two-year-old because that crazy
dishonest
blank fill in the blank yourself wants
you to do it after all of this time
after lying about everything lying about
social distancing and masking we know
now go to CBS go to Walgreens go to the
pharmacy of your choice pick up a box of
masks and you know what it says on the
side does not prevent covid
this crazy woman still will not reverse
I'm telling you she's a lizard we should
have stopped her we should have stopped
her and it could have been like the end
of Ace Ventura remember and then you see
the penis okay uh here's Bernie Sanders
and and I haven't played a video God
knows how long it's been with Bernie
Sanders I mean it's funny the revolution
just ate the guy he's completely
irrelevant he's just this old babbling
socialist before nobody cares about him
anymore but here's Bernie and suddenly
he's very upset about what we did to
kids now this is a guy who of course
loves the teachers union we'll get to
that in just a second but he's very
upset because they lock kids down and of
course he was for all the lockdowns he
loves government there's nothing that
Bernie Sanders loves more than
government and taking money so
government can do things and he loves
middle management and bureaucracy and
all that stuff but now you know three
years later he's upset because yeah a
couple kids are they're well the kids
are stupid now basically
and then I taught the kids
about the isolation they experienced in
covet the disruption for the first time
modern history of this country we all
went to school so I can kindergarten you
go to school these kids lives have been
disrupted
they didn't get the education that they
needed they didn't see their friends
they didn't play ball they didn't do
theater okay
and on top of that they're sitting
worrying about whether the planet is
going to be here for them
when they are older because of climate
change
they got all of these things on their
minds
don't worry they're worried because they
want to go to school like sure I did it
too everybody did it we all did it I did
don't go to school and put on the maps
to make sure you're vaccinated I doubt
they don't go to basketball they're not
going to theater I'm not sure am I doing
Jackie Mason or Bernie Sanders schmuck
like me and I can't do it like oh
Bernie
well Bernie this one's for you here's a
picture of you and teachers union
president Randy Weingarten do you love
her you old socialist buffoon yes he was
in on it with all of these people what
no I Bernie Sanders and kids come back
uh kids are also dying of heart attacks
at an increasing rate uh CBS covered
that
start of the corona buyer buyer pandemic
but a recent study found that young
people are actually most at risk in this
case according to Cedar Sinai Hospital
the number of heart attack deaths among
25 to 44 year olds in the U.S over the
first two years of the pandemic was 30
percent higher than predicted
but can I tell you
I don't know did we inject a whole bunch
of young people with all sorts of weird
stuff and we didn't know what was going
on did we strap weird on kids faces
and did we scare the hell out of them
about the environment that was the other
part of the birds
remember my video on prageru about The
Bravery deficit I think it was my third
uh prageru video that's all we need guys
just get over The Bravery deficit so
that when a woman like wolinsky says
something you just laugh in their face
and when a buffoon-like birdie says
something you laughing their face or
when Randy Weingarten or Joe Biden or
any of these people gave Pete any of
them when they say something no you are
liars you are all in on the lie and I
will not participate in the LIE
I will no longer participate in the LIE
right that's the great Alexander
soulchin it's in quote like all you have
to do to stop this thing is stop
participating in it people participate
in the lie because they're afraid if you
don't participate in the LIE the thing
will come get you and that might be true
to some degree but you think playing
that ever that never-ending game of of
Shaving a little bit of Truth off the
top do you think that'll save you I
don't think so I don't think so and when
you do the right thing you were rewarded
for it Rhonda santis and in Florida we
do education not indoctrination and so
that runs a foul of our standards and
you know many people agree with that in
other states we were just the only ones
that had you know the backbone to stand
up and do it because they call you names
and they demagogue you when you do it
but look I'm so sick of people not doing
what's right because they're worried
that people are going to call them names
we're doing what's right here
do what's right people will call you
names but then you get results and you
end up in this case this case living in
a state that is free and flourishing and
in line with your values that that's how
you do it to end Today's show I want to
Circle right back to the beginning we
started by showing you a video from this
one world government conference with
evil Palpatine talking about being a
master of the universe and all of the
horrible things that he will do to you
people
but then they oddly skyped in Elon Musk
and Elon Musk wasn't addict
one thing I should say and I know this
is called the world government Summit
um but I think we should be maybe a
little bit concerned about uh actually
becoming too much of a single World
Government
um if I may say that we want to avoid
creating a civilizational risk by having
um frankly this may sound a little odd
too much a cooperation between
governments
um you know if you know if you look at
say the history and the rise and fall of
civilizations
um the really all throughout history
civilizations have risen in Poland but
it hasn't meant the Doom of humanity as
a whole because they've been they've
been all these separate civilizations
that were separated by great distances
so I think we want to be a little bit
cautious about uh being too much of a
world of a single uh civilization
because if we are too much of a single
civilization then if we if the whole the
whole thing May collapse
it would not be good if the whole thing
collapsed now there's an awful lot of
reasons that some of the people in
charge right now are worthy of a
collapse but I don't want to deal with
the residual fall out of that collapse
and Elon is right when they want one
world government well if you have one
structure above all of us then some
goes down over there and it's gonna hurt
you over here so again we should be
reverting back to the way humans lived
for literally thousands of years where
you were dependent on your family and
your community and everything was local
and that's not to say technology is all
evil and it's not to say that there is
no way for governments of other well
certainly of states to work together on
things and then countries to work
together on things and all of that stuff
but something is very wrong about this
thing so it's quite beautiful that that
conference uh ended with Elon basically
putting a poop emoji on the entire thing
because uh he happens to be the richest
guy in the world who is fighting for
free speech in fighting for the ability
for Nations to exist for a purpose other
than just giving power over to Klaus
Schwab and those other people
folks that's our show for today I've got
a post game show coming up with a second
on local no I'm losing it now anyway
there's a post game we don't know why
we're doing a post game show it's just
something we do uh we'll vaccinate
people who come in it's very excited
children are depressed you can join us
at
rumorsreport.locals.com and if you know
I'll see you tomorrow
goodbye
America is a nation that can be defined
in a single word
I was going to put him for the foot
[Music]